a Taliban delegation is in Russia this
morning to talk about the prospects for
the withdrawal of US forces from
Afghanistan the extraordinary
development comes days after President
Trump announced us talks with the
Taliban had collapsed whatever the
outcome some Afghan women fear their
heart won freedom may be in jeopardy
Charlie d'Agata is in Kabul the Afghan
capital with their story good morning
well one phase of the Taliban talks has
resumed today in Moscow which may be a
sign of progress but women here feel
that even a partial power sharing
agreement with the Taliban will mean
that that progress is actually a
significant step backwards that is all
kind of frisk I get attached Vasya kufi
was an aspiring medical student when the
Taliban swept into Kabul pulling her
dreams of a brighter future from beneath
her for a woman it was not allowed and
it was not a properly to go to see a
doctor by herself they asked all the
woman to wear burkha which is not
Islamic so it's basically like a prison
you just said and walk and and look at
the world and the city from the windows
of your house like a prison like a
prison basically the former MP is now
the head of a party called movement for
change in Afghanistan women who were
brutally oppressed under the Taliban can
now be educated hold top jobs take part
in voting and run for office in talks at
the u.s. the Taliban have promised to
safeguard some of those rights like they
can hold a job but they can't be the
boss run for office but they can't be
President kufi is skeptical but still
hopes that the progress will be
irreversible because there is now a new
Afghanistan that accommodates woman
younger generation media so if anything
happens to the woman she can inform the
whole world by using all these
technology she says young women born in
the dying days of Taliban rule are now
18 years old and empowered by an
independence they've only ever known
when US forces first invaded this
country after 9/11 the name of that
mission was Operation Enduring Freedom
18 years later Enduring Freedom
exactly what women here are determined
to fight for now for CBS this morning
Saturday Charlie d'Agata Kabul